war so unemployment is still pretty high
in nevada as we're getting through the
pandemic
and that's why all this week we are
highlighting some ways to get help to
get you back to work
bianca holmen live this morning over at
csn with a look at some of the programs
helping those try and learn some new
careers bianca
hey good morning john so getting people
trained and on the job in less than a
year
csn is really transforming lives across
the valley i'm joined by belkis
rodriguez so tell us in addition to
those trainings and getting people
working
you also have those certifications that
can get them started
immediately exactly that's what we call
stackable certifications and their
industry certifications which makes our
students
much more marketable an example we've
got forklift training and this is one of
our
stackable certificates we attach
forklift training to all our
manufacturing training we attach the
safety osha
first aid cpr to all our workforce
trainings and
all the companies that we work with
everybody has a receiving dock and
actually we've got a couple of our
instructors here all right give us a
wave instructor
we got matt and santana and so we've got
females it's not just a traditional male
job
and this is an example pepsico says hey
if they come to us with osha
forklift we'll train them also here you
do this for him
and 17 to 20 bucks 25 an hour entry
level livable wages
and tell us you know like you said
santana she's gotten trained on this you
know maybe guys they're used to handling
big equipment but
you know tell us about the demographic
you're serving
with students who are coming in for
these certificates we serve all of
southern nevada we've got 60 percent
females all backgrounds single parents
we work closely with our partners so
people need laptops hot spots child care
transportation
our partners and csn workforce we're
ready to support them and serve them in
all those areas yeah because
that may be a word you say hey i want to
get trained but then i need somebody to
take care of my child while i am getting
that training how do i get there
all that kind of stuff tell us there are
you can get enrolled now there's ongoing
enrollment
exactly so we run forklift every week
and we're not workforce
development is not a traditional
semester so we run classes they're
accelerated
full-time day evening weekends and so
we're ready to meet
our our residents our community where
they are not everybody can come you know
a traditional semester yeah so again we
are meeting people like you said you're
meeting people where they are so if you
need child care who need money if you
need
internet they're doing it all they've
got instructors here to help you and
really
get you started on a new life and back
to work so again enrollment
happening now classes start at the end
of august we're going to have all this
information it's on the
on the twitter on the facebook on the
social media on our website
uh get started now call us now call yes
all right come on down and see them okay
you're ready to enroll them now all
right perfect so you say i got back to
you guys in the studio
very enthusiastic at csn bianca thank
you very much it's so important bianca
we've talked about finding work
the last week or so here not only to get
retrained but just to
add skills to your toolbox that when you
do apply for a job
you stand out more csn does a great job
with that we'll catch up with you later
on this morning